all right so this was our Squatch mobile
1.0 and Steve says that it's still good
to go and it's still safe well as you
can see this has now become the safety
vehicle for Squatch watch and let me
tell you why it's because it's got these
super resilient run-flat tires on it
dent resistant doors front and side
impact airbags and before you ever get
in your vehicle and take it for a spin
you always want to do a quick walk
through an inspection of it so keep that
in mind kids let's pop this head and
give her a look absolutely nothing I
think it all checks out that's actually
a storage compartment is this okay this
is unplugged absolutely it should be
unplugged if it was plugged in there
might be electricity running through
there and that's not safe because we've
got bodies of water everywhere around
here make sure this is strapped down
nice and tight are you going to take it
right now the most important thing about
a safety vehicle is the fit and as you
can tell this has a nice snug fit and
that's that's how you want your safety
vehicle see you guys later
I made it all the way down here safely
to well the safety vehicle got stuck
down here but it's a good thing we walk
brought Bree because she's really good
at carrying things on her back so she's
gonna get us out of here
she's really strong
recruited yeah what did you just steal I
was trying to do my knocks okay let's
see it stand back oh sorry
I might need a sturdier stick Oh would
you stand back all right we're about to
go out to get a little bit of target
practice so safety coordinator Steve is
all dressed up he's ready we got him
equipped
obviously you can't see him at all all
right
did you read me yeah I'd like to
introduce you to the 2013-2014 Squatch
sack in the Squatch sack
we've got Reynolds Wrap this is what I'd
like to use to be able to attract
Squatch I will sometimes get a nice roll
of this and just wave it around and
Squatch is all like girl give me some of
that Squatch lamps head lamps mostly
used for nighttime
Squatch hunting we've got some nature's
path organic peanut butter granola
what's really important about this a
Squatch does not like anything that
isn't organic he's from the nature he's
from the wild so obviously if he were to
shop anywhere he would shop at Whole
Foods
obviously mothers oprand
I think this actually was just my dad
spittin I thought about it alone
chocolate cake mix gluten-free something
you guys didn't know Squatch has celiac
disease he cannot have any gluten so
we're gonna make him a gluten-free cake
we're consider it like that I have a hat
because I'm cold
we've also got the Nestle's chocolate
chips Squatch he's got a sweet tooth I
am Justine I'm so excited because I am a
member of the Squatch watch team now
it's been two years since we've last
hunted for squad